this week on brian ross investigates
[Music]
it seemed like the perfect summer camp
for teenagers
folk music campfires and fun but a new
lawsuit says
the teen girls here became prey for male
counselors
the first time i was sexually assaulted
by a male counselor
was when i was 13 i was raped mandatory
massage trades the counselors organized
what was called
the underwear liberation movement 100
no and then they're they're multiple
serious crimes we'll talk with the chair
of the board of the organization
that runs the camp now saying they are
conducting their own investigation
but you are aware a woman who says at
the age of 13 she was raped at the camp
that's a serious crime
uh why have you not at least reported
that allegation
to law enforcement so that they can
investigate putting aside your own
internal investigation
it's our understanding that we were not
supposed to have to do that so if that
is something
why why wouldn't you plus this week's
winners and losers
in the media was chosen by the editors
of mediaite
see if you agree are you still telling
that lie are you telling new lies
from the law and crime trial network
this
is ryan ross investigators
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our viewers on
facebook live i'm brian ross joined as
always by my colleague ronda schwartz
and rhonda we begin with a troubling
story about a place
that was once thought to be one of the
most wonderful summer camps
anywhere in the country rhonda
brian the pandemic effectively shut down
summer camps last year
but the cdc has now put out guidelines
they say will make it safe for summer
camp to reopen
but as we discovered the risk of kovig
19 is
hardly the only danger children going
away to camp could face
[Music]
its promotional videos portray the
summer camp as an idyllic place for
children
safe from the outside world the
mountains of southern virginia
established by what is known as the
association for research
and enlightenment a.r.e generations of
families have attended the are camp over
the years
like hannah seen in one of the are
videos
six years ago i've been coming here to
camp for 19 years
because it's home
my grandmother attended camp my mother
and all of her siblings attended camp as
a teen it was this idyllic place where i
could be myself i felt understood
and i felt like i was finally connecting
with people
in the way that i wanted to and it was
just this incredibly special
place to me where i could be myself with
its folk songs from the 60s and its
mantra of mind body spirit connection
it seems so very special to many like
lindsay
it was a place that i
thought was my spiritual home a place in
the summer that i could go
have fun and feel safe but
unfortunately it wasn't that and now
according to a lawsuit filed by lindsay
and hannah and others
the campus where a dangerous cycle of
continued sexual abuse
and cover-ups has lasted generations
i started to notice when i was 14 and 15
that um the older female campers and
also the other 14 year olds around
me were being preyed upon by
older male staff members hannah says
teen girls were encouraged to be part of
what was called
the liberated underwear movement all of
the
children who wanted to would strip down
to their bras and underwears or just
underwear sometimes staff members
specifically male staff members would
participate with us
and was it more than just a liberated
movement
um yes i would say
looking back it absolutely was
i remember feeling sexualized and
very uncomfortable with the entire
situation
even worse she says was the so-called
massage train
seen in one of the are videos that's
hannah
as a teen i mean sexualized i
mean touched without our consent you had
no say
in who touched you it was just you stood
behind somebody
and whoever wanted to would stand behind
you
and oftentimes when you are a tall woman
like myself
being hugged by somebody from behind
you're being touched in a place that you
don't want to be touched
um which was oftentimes very
uncomfortable for me
did you at any point say no or try to
report this yes
when i was uh 20
i was sexually assaulted by
a senior director
he had made advances to me
all summer long he
touched me inappropriately all summer
long as well as
sexually harassed me relentlessly
and i said no countless times and
eventually got so
um scared of him
that i reported him directly to the camp
manager
but hannah says nothing happened the
senior director she says
assaulted her was rehired for the
following summer term
what finally led you to speak out and to
bring this lawsuit
i finally spoke up about it and um i was
ostracized from the community and blamed
because
his feelings needed to be prioritized
which is a common
theme in our community is women and
girls
are taught that we need to sacrifice our
own feelings and overcome
our feelings of discomfort and
anger because these men
who have this karma or this
soul that they need to work on
need the community and need the love and
light
that they will get from this community
lindsay says she was told the same thing
after she says she was repeatedly
assaulted the first time i was
sexually assaulted by a male counselor
was when i was 13
i was raped and i reported it and i was
silenced and victim-blamed lindsay says
when she returned to the camp a few
years later
she was ordered to apologize to the
counselor she says
raped her and i was forced to
confront him i didn't know he was going
to be there until i showed up
and it was horrific i had a severe
traumatic reaction
i panicked i was crying i was freaking
out um
as a 17 year old even it just brought
back all of these flashbacks and
feelings of
initially losing my safe space a place
that my whole family had been a place
where i found many
dear relationships that i still have
but the setting itself the are has
creating it created an environment where
children and young women such as myself
were not safe so when i was confronted
with him
it was a horrible experience
so you reported that he raped you and he
was not fired he continued to work there
yes and also assaulted
other young children and then you were
ordered to
do public forgiveness of him
yes there was a ceremony held very
cult-like
um for context too this place is in a
very remote location
i at multiple times tried to leave the
program
and i did not have a car i did not have
a cell phone
and they were just gaslighting me
and saying it was my job to forgive him
and reintegrate him into this community
because the values of this community are
unconditional love and so they said they
loved me
and they loved him and they wanted us
all to be like a family
um so i was forced into the situation
and
it was horrific to say how did that feel
to be in that situation
even now talking about it it's very
difficult for me to
let down my guard and really show
the full emotion behind it because it's
so triggering it's
i can't describe to you how horrific it
is to be ambushed by
people that i'm supposed to be able to
trust and
to feel gaslit by my entire community
because so many people
are brainwashed into thinking that yes
it's our
soul's duty it's our karmic duty to
unconditionally love and forgive
everyone no matter what harm they cause
according to the lawsuit the camp
repeatedly failed to call law
enforcement about such attacks
and the lawyer for the young women
stephen este says an
allegation has now been filed with local
authorities
but you would agree this is a serious
crime as alleged by lindsay
100 no and then there there are multiple
serious crimes that were committed by uh
by by not only on lindsay but up by
other clients
at that camp and yet
no serious investigation as far as you
know as far as i know no
the lawsuit names the association of
research and enlightenment
and its executive director kevin
taudeshi
our goal in bringing this lawsuit is to
hold the aree accountable
number one uh and and to stop this from
from happening
again the other thing we want to do is
we want to put the shame back where it
belongs
because the shane belongs with ari who
failed to protect these
young children who who fostered this
cult-like atmosphere of sexual abuse and
sexual assault the former campers behind
the lawsuit say
they are sad that a place with such
great potential
failed so spectacularly i want this to
be an example for
this is what not to do at a children's
summer camp do not allow people
that perpetrate abuse to be rehired
we need systems in place that prevent
this and that's true across all
communities i believe the campus said
they're looking into it they're going to
investigate what do you say about that
what do you think should happen honestly
that
the are is built
on a crumbling foundation
on a foundation that was not meant
to keep children safe and to keep
women and the people who work for it
safe
and i think that it's time to put that
to an
end and protect children and women
when we come back we'll hear from the
people who run to the camp
what do they know and when did they know
it you're watching brian ross
investigates on the law and crime
trial network
as we heard the former campers are
alleging in their lawsuit that there was
an effort to maintain
and cover up a system of rampant sexual
abuse
the charge the people who run the cap at
the group called are
strongly deny we're joined now by laura
little who's the chair of the board at
are
this little thank you so much for being
here tonight thank you for reaching out
to us brian we appreciate it
what is your reaction to this lawsuit
with the damning accusations
you know uh these allegations are
are so disturbing there are
actually painful to read um
we're all in great distress and we've
been aware of them for 11 months
and we realized pretty early on that we
needed to do a third party investigation
and that's what we have have initiated
and we're
toward the final stages of the
investigation
and we will be making steps to
toward accountability and toward
changing our policies
procedures whatever needs to happen to
make this right
the lawsuit alleges that you've
essentially covered up somebody at your
organization
has covered up uh rampant sexual abuse
yeah that's just absolutely not true as
soon as these allegations became
uh available to us as soon as they were
posted on a facebook page and it was the
first time any of us on the board were
aware of it
we immediately got to work and we have
been working
really hard the last 11 months
to follow up to work with a really
professional
third-party investigation organization
so that we can get to what the truth of
the matter is
and know what we need to do as an
organization
we absolutely want to do the right thing
we're not trying to cover up
anything one of the young women who is
suing you
says she was raped at the age of 13 at
the camp
were you aware of that was anybody at
the camp she said she reported it
and she was made to essentially
apologize to the person
who she says raped her that's just an
awful awful thing to hear
and and i am not aware of that situation
uh at this point what we have done in
our investigation was
ask people to report who have had
first-hand experiences people like the
the allegation in the lawsuit and if
that comes through
our system we will it's being
investigated thoroughly
but has this been reported to local law
enforcement that a 13 year old was raped
at the camp
i am not aware at this point that a 13
year old i don't have the facts that a
13 year old was
raped other than what's in the lawsuit
and
so we're not able to report something
that we did not know
but you are aware a woman who says at
the age of 13
she was raped at the camp that's a
serious crime
why have you not at least reported that
allegation to law enforcement so that
they can investigate putting aside your
own internal investigation
um it's our understanding that we were
not supposed to have to do that
so if that is something why why wouldn't
you
why wouldn't you do that
we would
would do whatever the right thing is
we're that's what we're trying to do
do you doubt the word of this young
woman i don't know this young woman so i
cannot say
one way or the other are you aware of
what was called the
liberated underwear movement
i am i was not familiar with that until
i read it in the lawsuit
no what do you make of that it it does
not fit with the ideals of our
organization
whatsoever and uh so again those these
are the kinds of things that we
are hoping to uncover in our
investigation
and we look forward to hearing what we
what the investigators have come up with
both women who were involved in a
lawsuit told us that they were
essentially made to
apologize and forgive the men who they
say
attacked and assaulted them is that
consistent with what happens at that
camp
if that is true it is not a part of
our ideals it's not something that we
would approve of
whatsoever and it makes me personally
extremely sad
and extremely distressed i'm very
concerned for anyone
that that would have happened to without
a doubt no that is not the way we expect
staff to
uh to conduct themselves that is
not part of our policy and procedure
you've had this for 11 months have you
taken any steps to
fire anyone at this point
we're waiting for the end of the
investigation we have not
uh the camp has been closed it was
closed in 2020 it's closed
this year it may never re-open but we
won't know
the answers to those questions until we
get in through the final stages of the
investigation
mr these two women who we've talked to
who are part of the lawsuit say they
came to the camp
it was a spiritual home for them they
were crushed by what happened
what do you say to them
anyone who feels like they have been
harmed through any
thing to do with edgar cayce's are he
has my
greatest greatest sympathy and i am
so so sorry for anything that may have
happened to anyone
at any of our activities and
the you know as i said to you that
reading these allegations is just deeply
deeply personally
painful and uh as i've read through them
i've had
had my own set of tears because if this
has happened to anyone it is not
acceptable
to this organization and there and
people will be accountable
lauren little chair of the board of art
thank you so much for being with us here
tonight
thank you brian the sheriff in the
virginia county where the camp is
located says he will
investigate any allegation brought to
his attention
coming up next the winners and losers in
the media this week
see if you agree with the choices made
by the editors of mediaite
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media
as chosen by the editors of mediaite and
we're joined by aidan mclaughlin who's
the editor-in-chief of mediaite which
like
the law and crime trial network is part
of the dan abrams media empire
nathan begin with your winner cnn for
hiring away a reporter from
fox news eight that's right so fox news
white house correspondent uh kristen
fisher
announced on friday in the early evening
that she's leaving fox news
uh at the end of a live hit on special
report which is brett bear's program
she didn't say where she was going in
that live hit
but a source told mediaite that fisher
is joining cnn as a space correspondent
one interesting aspect of this
announcement is that it was of course
made at 6 pm on friday
which was almost certainly at the behest
of fox news
who is probably looking to keep this
somewhat on the down low that cnn
had poached one of its star reporters
fisher's very well respected in the
industry and at fox news
she's an impressive reporter and has a
great on-air presence
so cnn fox's news's loss here is cnn's
game
a smart hire for cnn no doubt the loser
this week
newsmax who had the misfortune in live
television
to have a guest who essentially turned
on them former obama
speech writer david litt was asked about
elon musk and changed the topic
i mean what happened on snl this weekend
was that people
made stuff up and then said it on
television like it's true
and that actually happens pretty
frequently in american tv for example in
2020
dominion voting system sued newsmax over
its false claims
about election fraud newsmax was lying
to its own viewers and newsmax had to
settle
that lawsuit so i'm actually i just need
to check in are you still telling that
lie are you telling new lies
aidan you can only imagine them tearing
off their hair in the control room that
newsmax has their
guests turned on them i mean absolutely
brutal stuff there i mean
what i love about this clip is you
really see that uh david litt who was a
former uh
obama speechwriter who was the guest
there he came
in with an idea and he executed it
perfectly um
it was you know you you want to feel bad
for newsmax and the anchor there a
little bit
and then you remember that david lit is
right uh newsmax lied about the 2020
election on air repeatedly
and then got sued for billions of
dollars by dominion
which is a voting systems company that
was caught up in those lies
uh and newsmax eventually uh apologized
um and issued a massive retraction of
its election coverage
um and a correction um it's it's odd
there that the uh the anchor the newsmax
anchor didn't
cite that correction and say you know
we've we've apologized for this and
we've corrected uh and point to the
statement that they issued
instead uh the segment ended very
abruptly and uh after he kept trying to
bring it back to
snl it's a really embarrassing moment
for newsmax there
i don't think we'll see david lit on
newsmax again soon
certainly all right thank you so much
for joining us
they did it's a tough lesson to learn
live tv well thanks again for joining us
and thanks to all of you for watching
and thanks to our great staff here at
long crime for guinea is on the air
and off the air once again
[Music]
you